I think a system like hello health could
definitely encourage more people to go
into primary cabs.
So however,
you know,
for the past at least 10 years,
about 5% of doctors have been going into
primary care.
Um,
most high performing health care systems
in the world,
uh,
have about 75% primary care doctors in
25% specialists and America.
Um,
whereabouts exactly opposite.
Uh,
we have 75% specialists and we're about
two generations of doctors behind the
curve on this one.
So,
um,
it,
once boomers retire or die,
uh,
primary care sort of dead with them.
Um,
which is unfortunate because that's
what,
you know,
that's what sort of controls your
experience and your health.
Um,
that's the person that you should be
able to depend on.
Um,
but right now,
I mean,
specialists are making double,
triple,
quadruple,
uh,
as much as,
as primary care doctors.
So,
you know,
and seeing like half as many patients.
So what's the incentive for doctors to
go into primary care?
Um,
there's not much,
uh,
hello health,
a system like hello health,
uh,
that encourages and pays primary care
doctors for communication.
And pays them more on par with,
with,
um,
specialists would absolutely I think
work.
Uh,
then there are other issues where,
you know,
the medical sort of institutions devalue
the,
uh,
art talent of primary care in exchange
for,
you know,
the big bad neurosurgeon,
um,
respect they get.
Um,
I don't know,
that's going to be really interesting.
I mean that's the kind of stuff I'm sort
of thinking about right now.
Um,
what I think is most interesting about
the death of primary care and the con
and this then the rise of the Internet
as well.
Um,
when you think about it,
um,
the Internet connecting me with
information and connecting me with
patients is actually doing something
really,
really interesting to,
uh,
the practice of medicine.
Um,
you spend about one hour a year with
doctors and about 8,000,
765 without doctors.
So what does that mean to your life?
Well,
doctors aren't the cure all for your
health.
I mean,
you are right.
So,
I mean,
you're sort of like the CEO of your own
body and your doctor is a sort of a
consultant,
you call it every once in a while,
right?
So that basically means,
um,
there are a ton of tools that are just
now springing up,
uh,
that connect us with good information
that's relevant to you as well as
connect us with other patients who are
having similar problems as you.
So,
um,
I hope that the Internet can prevent,
uh,
office visits,
especially primary care visits,
uh,
and help people take care of themselves
better is tools.
Now,
um,
you know,
you can connect with doctors via video
chat.
Uh,
I think those tools have serious issues
there because nobody really uses video
chat with strangers and who are the
doctors that are on video chat where
they're seeing patients in our office,
you know.
Um,
but I think that there are opportunities
to build so to systems like this,
the issue is how do you,
when people need a prescription maybe,
um,
for say antibiotics,
uh,
and I can't really be done over the
Internet,
uh,
with today's sort of laws and
regulations.